let's talk about wild mountain time it's
a beautiful movie it's gorgeous
and um shot in such a beautiful location
and in this film you were required to
have an irish accent
which is can can be tricky it is
and and i studied you know before i went
there i had recordings
and uh things to help me but when i got
there
everybody was irish so that was
intimidating
and i had to get used to that and uh but
it
i hadn't been to ireland for some reason
there are places i've
i've never been and never been to
ireland no
and it was really uh beautiful it was in
a place
some hours outside of dublin in the
country and
uh there really were rainbows and it was
green and it was moody and
uh uh
it was just beautiful the place we
stayed in uh
had a rookery where they raised hawks
and
falcons and owls and uh
it was uh it was a magical
experience yeah it's a you know
wonderful actors
oh yeah i mean uh the the cast is
you have a you have a fantastic cast
john patrick shanley emily blunt
jamie dornan john hamm development
yeah just and and i don't know if you
noticed it the
the irish accent i mean obviously there
are so many different kinds of irish
accent but it's very musical
to me that's when i come from 100
irish um and when i've gone back to
ireland i've always been transfixed by
the musicality of the way they talk
it almost sounds like they're singing
when they talk you know yes
well that whole part of the world there
is that that
thing with language uh ireland wales
scotland you know
sure um but i hadn't been to ireland and
i
i want to go back yeah well
soon i'm hoping we'll all be able to
travel you know that'd be nice
you know you've been you've been inside
now for as long as probably the rest of
us
just stuck inside the last time i was
the new york
uh city was uh you know eight nine
months ago
yeah march yeah um well we have a clip
here
and and this is a clip and you can tell
just even in this clip
uh and this is the scene with you and
and emily blunt just how gorgeous
the location is i mean lots of it seems
like a lot of
animals farm country was this anything
that you
grew up with at all in your experience
no i was born in new york city and um
this is really different yeah yeah now
you don't encounter a lot of
sort of draft horses in new york cows
cows and cows wearing cow bells
yes and cows cows are misunderstood
they're
actually quite aggressive oh really
yeah maybe just with you maybe
maybe but they'd get a look in their eye
and then go for you you know
that's just you that's nobody else
nobody else has ever said that about a
cow
that's them realizing who you are and
wanting to you know
wanting to get in on that you know
that's all that's all that is
just it's turf
[Laughter]
you're not having turf wars with cows
well here's a clip we're going to show
now uh from uh
wild mountain time where you're talking
to your daughter who's played by emily
blunt
let's take a look are you in love with
anthony it's more than love
don't play now go while your damn gates
are open no i'm not
i'm not done with you it's not normal
i don't care you'll never marry well
then neither will i
and he will be in his house and i'll be
in mine rosemary
be quick i need to pee and you'd sell to
a yank would you he's a riley he's a
yank
your trespasser now dropped his plot or
i'll kill you
would you have the place called an
auction anthony will never marry or he
will
wake up look to yourself no if it comes
to that i'll freeze my eggs
what i freeze my eggs if he's slow
i'll wait you should freeze your whole
body if you're waiting for that
i believe he will come to me i need to
settle
wild mountain time is available in
theaters and
on demand you must have shot this just
before covid
yes uh in october of last year wow
doesn't that seem like a million years
ago it certainly does